so if I have the formula what else do
you need for some others say guess what
I want to go build an x bridge Wow okay
wise guy
give it a shot it's more difficult to
succeed in the markets than it is to
succeed in the Olympics reduce risk
without reduce in return think of it
it's like going to a horse race you're
not gonna pick the best horse
diversification is a boring formula it's
outfitted etc etc I went from nothing
you asked me capitalism it is in danger
of dying I understand a philosopher
where your goal is down it's a
complicated question kind of pumping
money into Wow way you got to play by my
rules it doesn't work that way which
produces better results oh you're not
letting me answer your question Wow US
China who needs who mourns you have a
dangerous set of circumstances history
has taught us that so I'm telling this
discussions taking place bet on it
[Music]
so today I'm sitting with Ray Dahlia for
those of you that don't know who Ray
Dalio is Ray Dalio is the author of
principles which is you know the work
he's done in his life and his philosophy
similar to what Marcus Aurelius wrote in
meditations many years ago this is for
entrepreneurs and business people if you
haven't read it you definitely have to
read it but again if you don't know who
he is I'll give you some perspective
here
he's a 25th richest man in America 58 in
the world he can write 18700 checks for
1 million dollars for those who don't
like Bugattis he can buy ninety three
hundred Bugattis that's the kind of
wealth he has but he's not just known
for that he also go the company that has
roughly around a hundred twenty-five
billion dollars or more of money under
management called Bridgewater associates
is the chairman founder and CEO ray
Dahlia ray thank you for making the time
thank you for making it yes and we kind
of wanted to create a romantic setting
this is like a notebook esque for you
maybe you're gonna open up and tell us
some of your insight even deeper than
principles well I don't know about your
comment about romantic but it is a
pretty setting it is a great setting yes
so ray for some some people who don't
obviously one of the things you and I
talk about on the phone I come from the
Morgan Stanley background that's kind of
how I got into the financial industry
how did you get into the business
yourself in the 1960s I was caddying at
a golf course and then and the stock
market was hot at the time so I was 12
years old and I was talking about stocks
with the people that I was catting with
and I took my catting money and I
decided I would invest I didn't know
what I was doing first sock I bought was
a company which was the only company I
ever heard of that was selling for less
than five dollars a share that was my
criteria because I figured I could buy
more shares and that meant if it went up
I would make more money obviously stupid
mmm-hmm but I got lucky the first
company I bought was a company that was
about to go broke but somebody acquired
it and it tripled and I thought this
game is easy so I got hooked how often
was that what was a timeline of you
best thing to a triple link oh I don't
remember exactly but I would say was
probably maybe a little less than a year
a year I don't pretty quick Patrol I
mean I can really hook you yeah
when an acquisition comes along so and
then I got hooked on the game I know
your dad was a musician jazz and ain't a
but how did you get into even being
interested in that was it listening to
what they were talking about the guys
that were golfing when you were caddy in
or at the time everybody played a little
bit around you know the words they were
taking the stock market was very hot so
but so I'd walk around and we'd be
chatting you know I did be asking them
questions and they would think it was a
little odd that I was asking them
questions and they were nice to a young
kid and so we would talk about it and
I'd say what stock and ones you know and
so that's how it happened
and at that time if I'm 12 years old and
I'm your friend how was revalued what
was your personality like will you shy
were you curious were you confident what
was your personality well the first word
that you mentioned that comes is curious
okay I'm very very curious all right I'm
not shy I'm but I'm polite you know I
don't know if they're playing golf I
want to do what they want me to do but
if you get a nice person and I'm curious
and get into an interesting conversation
that they're interested in it's great
now you carry for some interesting
people I know one of them being
President Nixon was he a president when
you were counting or not yet no not he
wasn't yet no he had lost the election
you know his first and then he it was
post that got it then the Duke of
Windsor and some other people that's
right and there was Wellington is there
was a Wall Street crowd you know and
that led to my being able to clerk on
the floor of the New York Stock Exchange
because one of those guys we were
talking about the markets and so on yeah
and he had a specialist firm in other
words a floor brokerage firm on the
floor and so he said hey why don't you
in your summer job come down and clerk
so between college and my summer job my
going to business school I got the clerk
on the floor of the knock sock exchange
but along the way you know those those
guys made a big difference in my life
do you remember any dialogue with
Richard Nixon or no was there any
specific that stuck till today or not
know he was there wasn't he wasn't
chatting okay that's it's funny I asked
Clint Hill I don't know if you know
Clint Hill now Clint Hill was the Secret
Service age and when JFK got shot he's
the first guy that jumped on the top of
the car
ooh and he was a secret service for
Richard Nixon it says he wouldn't talk
too much he was always kind of to
himself and quiet it seems it's the same
thing with you as well so now you go to
high school who are you in high school
same curious where you're playing sports
were you a 4.0 GPA kid who are you in
high school no I was the opposite of a
4.0 GPA kid like I I didn't like high
school I I did like playing with my pals
and and you know having a good time you
know there was so much of learn this
remember this and I think first of all I
think have a very bad rope memory what I
mean rope memory is if something doesn't
have a reason for being what it is
within its context like let's say phone
numbers or names and so on I it's
challenging for me to remember it but
also I didn't understand the purpose of
it I didn't get it hooked in it wasn't
curious curiosity based it wasn't
interesting and so I was a lousy high
school student I barely got in on
probation to CW post college which is no
Ivy League college but I'm very very
curious at the time for lots of
different things what people would say
everything from politics to you know
markets and how things work you know not
mechanical things but how the system
epital
I was up involved with politics quiet
politics well I was young enough at the
time that I remember
Eisenhower going to Nixon the debate in
Kennedy and I was inspired by John
Kennedy and that era and so all along
then it was interesting and so when
Bobby Kennedy was running for the Senate
it was in New York
I got very actively involved I was just
it was in high school and so that part
of it was interesting to me
so anyway politics markets gilina games
were you a card guy backgammon chests
like the judge I don't I play backgammon
you play back in yeah played backgammon
I play I like Jess I played some chess
but no it was mostly my game was the
markets because the two things went
together
okay the two things went together what
was going on in the world politics and
so on
and what was going on in the markets and
to me it was an ability to bet on what
was going on in the markets right
in other words bet on what's going on in
the world because what was going on in
the world would affect what was going on
their markets so to me that enthralled
me because it wasn't just theoretical
like if you read a you know newspaper
and everybody talks politics and they
say you what's gonna happen oh yeah
bet on it make your your bet and the
markets gives you an objective scoring
of how well you are at betting on these
macro global macro economic political
things is that is that a pretty common
thread amongst everybody in your world
meet when I say your world I'm talking
you Buffett I'm talking people that are
investors that pay very close attention
to politics because so does Buffett he
you know he's a guy that was coming to
pay attention to that is that very
common or not really I'm not really okay
not really in terms of let's say global
macro investor most people find a
particular niche let's say I would say
even in Warren Buffett's case he will
focus a lot particularly on the cash
flows you're exchanging one cash flow
for another cash flow that has to do
with value investing in such things or
man you you pay it well
investing is an exchange of a lump sum
payment for a future clash flow right so
it's maybe the cash you have or even the
cash you can borrow but you can take a
certain amount of cash and you buy
something and what you're getting is a
cash flow like your investment than that
and they all compare so when you can
take it at a certain amount of cash that
let
so you could borrow it at 3% and I can
invest it at 6% then I'm going to make a
three percent spread and it's the
constant calculation of what that would
be let's say Warren Buffett's type of
type of approach and that would be most
important that's more value investing
then you do with how the world is
changing and what the world is going to
be like and that's a little bit
different or you go to niches you know a
niche might be you follow a particular
industry and what will the new AI
technologies be for example and how do I
bet on that
or it may end up being that you look at
certain distress debt but quite often
it's a much more narrow specialist type
of thing so it's a little bit like
doctors you know a doctor might be a
specialist in this there are a lot of
specialists and then the idea of global
macro brings me into a different world
than most of the menu that you as well
because you're more diversified when I
look at the way you set up your
portfolio it's not as niches that all
right I'm big on diversity or very big
like patient of knowing how knowing how
to adverse by well is more important
than almost anything people don't
understand this is that an evergreen
principle yes that's it evergreen
principle and the reason I'm saying that
the way it is it's almost like a casino
making its money okay okay the way that
you do it is you get an edge so now when
you have to make a bet I've got a bet
against the whole world the world has
view on something is reflected in the
price so when I think something is
attractive or unattractive that means I
have to bet against the whole world and
whether that's right or not that's
difficult I get it right you know more
often than I get it wrong but I'm going
to get it wrong sometimes and so when
you can take a lot of different bets
what you can do is like the casino
you'll get your average that your bet
would be but you'll reduce your risk
event one of those tables not being the
table that's paying off and so that
margin then so I can reduce my risk
without reducing my return by knowing
how to diverse
if I and I'd say that's particularly
true important for the people or
listening near investors because what
they've got to do some risk without
reduce in return that's right that's the
specialty that's right
elaborate a little bit more if you don't
mind on that so redo some risk without
reducing the return because a lot of
times if I'm reducing the risk it means
my return is also going Lord but you're
saying no no what I'd even reduce them
to return right I mean that's a
high-paying skill set yeah it's the most
important thing that you could start off
doing if you have a number of equally
good likely bets but they're
uncorrelated like the casino you know
one table is going to get me a margin
like this but take another table and it
makes me a margin like this but I might
have volatility about those let me take
all those investments that I think will
make 10 percent so that's my return but
they're uncorrelated with each other
that means I'll still get to 10 I don't
lower my 10 but my diversification means
I lower my risk so I improved my return
to risk ratio ah is that an art that you
can teach oh yeah yeah I wrote about it
in there's a what I call a section in
this book the holy grail of investing
it's a three pages long and it explains
basically this important thing because
when that epiphany happened to me and
how I would do it it changed everything
by being able to do that because how old
I can improve through diversification I
can improve my return to risk ratio by a
factor of five so by diversifying okay
the return relative to the risk I can
keep my returns the same and reduce my
risk to one-fifth if I know how to
diversify well and that's why I'm
explaining it's not all that complicated
it's simply explained in the book but in
any case that is the holy grail of
investing ok that's a big thing if you
start to know that that's what you're
going for
it changes everything and it's so
important for the average person is
listening and don't let me explain why
that is because the average person who's
listening too many people think that
they can go into this very difficult
zero-sum game of betting against the
consensus and be right you know what I
mean
in other words investor says I'm gonna
go in the markets I'm gonna make money
betting against the consensus and be
right right because the consensus is
built into the price okay okay that's
what's up
so it's think of it it's like going to a
horse race and there's handicaps okay
you're not going to pick the best horse
and you're not going to pick the best
company a terrible company can be a
better investment than a terrific
company a terrible company could be a
better investment just like the terrible
horse can be a better with because the
odds that are changing let you go into
that and that becomes the longshot but
because the longshot is going to pay off
twenty five to one right if he comes in
that you could just as likely bet on the
longshot as the leader and it's going to
be equally likely that you're gonna make
money right otherwise you otherwise the
market would be doing the opposite well
the market is like that right in other
words if everybody believes that
something's going to be terrific
okay then everybody's betting on it and
its price is high so it's not what's
best necessarily it's what's best
relative to what's in the price what's
discounted so let me ask you saying have
your formula let's just I have you for
you you got around what fifteen hundred
employees with Bridgewater is the number
right about 50 ah that's always so if I
have the formula that you have what
other what edge do you have that
somebody else has to have as a character
as an individual quality discipline
patience what else do you need for some
others say guess what I want to go brick
build the next bridge Wow okay before I
go to that I want to pit complete my
thought on this notion shove you was an
average investor in why diversification
so important in order for you
to win in the game like you're gonna go
in and pick what's a good investment you
are playing against others you have to
realize that because that's it's all in
the odds it's like when you go to the
track you're going to have to play
against the handicappers okay so it is
very difficult for you to beat me or to
beat others who were putting 1,500
people and hundreds of millions of
dollars into how to win in that game
right and there's a lot of people and I
find it challenging I find it difficult
so it's difficult to win in that game
it's it's difficult to win in that game
individually by placing the bets it's
difficult to win in that game it's more
difficult to succeed in the markets than
it is to succeed in the Olympics
okay people but people don't realize
that they think I'm going to go have an
obsession or okay but there are more
people trying to do it in the markets
that are trying to do it in the Olympics
and so nobody would say I'm gonna run
and compete in the Olympics when you
realize how difficult that is okay but
you can diversify well anybody could
diversify well so if we look at what the
world will be like in five years or
three years or one year okay like we're
coming in the presidential election we
have all these things going on okay you
want to bet on it
okay wise guy give it a shot that's is
that is that easy
okay well the only way I can do it is I
need to diversify my bets well I
wouldn't want to concentrate on any one
of those and I tried it I take like the
casino I will take I'll take that bet
and I'll take this bet and I'll take a
bunch of those bets but for you was the
average investor you're probably not
going to even be able to pick which
horses got the the edge what relative to
the handicappers okay and so
diversification that is the thing that I
would say particularly for anybody it is
the most important thing it's if you
know how to do that well so that's why
I'm saying you know that page those
couple of pages here was something I
wanted to pass along to you you'll see a
lot of people will say that's a boring
formula or it's an
outdated you know you'll be in the
industry install this whole
diversification is a boring formula
etcetera etc I'm I'm just trying to say
I went from nothing you asked me okay I
my dad's a jazz musician middle class or
lower middle class family I had nothing
other than parents who cared me and I
could go to a good public school and
that was the only thing I had and if I
took that and I say ok Here I am with
the things that has happened over the
markets and making money and building a
business and so on there was there a
limited number of principles that I want
to pass along to people because I think
if they can get those principles that
that would be extremely valuable and
this is not boring so when I come back
and you say okay that Arkin lodge or is
not boring that was a very successful
and exciting arc in life and this is one
of those principles so if you take
diversifying well how to diversify well
please go understand that principle it's
only a couple of pages please go
understand that principle because when
you have savings and you think how much
money do I need for my kids education or
my retirement or whatever it is and so
on and if you don't know how to do this
well you're risking a lot and if you do
it well and so on it produces an
enormous amount of opportunity so you
have 1500 employees here how many of
them do research for you specifically
tied to politics election what's going
to happen how much are you spending time
studying that part of it since you're
saying two things that intrigue you in
high school politics and economy and how
it's tied to each other are you guys
focused heavily on study and what's
happened in politics as well regulation
laws a lot of well well we need to we
need to more so today than we have ever
had to why do you say that well because
we're in a period of time which is very
much like the late 1930s there are three
main things that exist today and are the
biggest forces in what is happening that
did not exist before in our lifetimes
but existed in the 1930s okay and if you
look at history they repeat themselves
and the first is that there's a very
large gap between the rich and the poor
and as a result big gap in politics
between the left and the right okay it's
become more extreme and in this coming
election it will be more extreme and
around the world it's more extreme
that's why we see the rise in population
okay that has very big implications on
how the economy will work and how taxes
will happen let me give an example that
the corporate tax cut which happened was
a big boost for stocks because you own a
stock and they had pay Lex taxes the
stock is worth more the company's worth
more if there is a let's say a Democrat
elected there's a high probability
almost certainty that that would be
route to old bat sure so one of those or
in other matters and it matters in a lot
of different ways more than it ever
mattered before so item number one the
wealth gap in the political gap the
second factor interest rates are close
to zero and the printing of money to buy
assets is not as effective in the old
days in the normal days if the economy
didn't do so well you'd hit it with a
little joke of stimulation you lover it
lower the interest rate and put some
cash out there you give it a hype and
then it goes okay when you get to zero
or close to zero
you can't blower those interest rates so
we're close to that level in the United
States we're at those levels negative
interest rates in Europe negative
interest rates in Japan that baby ain't
going to work any more when you try to
lower that in terms of that won't happen
okay that's limited and then there what
they do is they go out and they print
money and they buy financial assets and
that is not working as well because what
happens is when you buy the financial
assets it goes into the hands of this of
who own financial asset investors and
what they do is they put it into more
investments that notion of putting it
into more investments makes those
investments go up in price which is
great for the people who have the
investments but not so great for the
people who don't have the invest
it widens the wealth gap and it's a its
own challenge and it's not going to be
stimulative and you'll see it so item
number two that didn't exist in our
lifetimes before but did exist in the
late 30s was is that item number three
that exists is that there's a rise of a
power to challenging an existing world
power
China China rising to challenge the
United States and if you look at through
history when there's existing world
powers and there's rising of a
challenging power there is a conflict
there are conflicts and they've led to
wars in the last 500 years that's
happened 16 times then to 12 of those
times they had there were Wars there
were four types of wars that happened
simultaneously we always think shooting
each other and sending people and bodies
into wars and that kind of war but but
there they all have four types of wars
they have a trade war they often start
with a trade war 1930s smoot-hawley
Tariff there is a technology war there
is a geopolitical war like is happening
with China what will it mean for Asia
Asian countries and there's a capital
war capital war in all of these cases so
for example just recently the Trump
administration said that they're
considering shutting off capital to
China a certain flow of capital to China
well it's not happened before you have
to go back to World War two and in World
War Two and a number of wars that other
countries have had they have a capital
war which means that that they can say
the Trump administration can say to the
Chinese
you know those trillion dollars of bonds
that you own well we're not going to pay
you or we're gonna do this or that these
types of wars and how to how does money
flow between autorai who need to hock
I'll digress into that but I just wanted
to make clear that at number three
so these are factors short one wealth
and political gap extreme number two
monetary policy can't so if we have a
downturn and they're at each other's
throats serious number three the
conflict with with China these things
have played out now when you ask how do
you play the game in China us that's a
that's a conversation but I just wanted
to clarify that the nature of the
powerfulness so now when you look at why
is politics more important today than it
was because that will determine in the
markets what will happen in in the
markets in the economy right in number
one that wealth gap who you elect will
have a big economic and market impact
from number two the absence of monetary
policy will have a big market impact as
to what will be done and number three
this geopolitical war which involves
those four things technology and so on
will have a big impact so that's why
it's more important than ever so
question for you what US China who needs
whom or because China was communism you
write about it in your paper why and how
capitalism needs to be reformed which
we're gonna put the link below if you
haven't read it you got to read this
paper so who needs two more their
communism they look at what's going on
in the world they notice us is doing
good this whole book about Karl Marx
communist manifesto flopped it impact a
lot of people were killed it didn't work
my family happened then we're communists
then they look around Russia says hey
Reagan comes maybe you got a consider
capitalism Russia kind of starts tuna
now China is looking at it they keep
communism at the power at the top where
there's not really freedom of press but
economy maybe let's test capitalism now
they're coming up isn't the leader still
us where they rely on us even though if
they want to compete against them
because I know the sole plan to have
what made in China 2025 with IP and all
these things they're taking with the
whole plan I'm sure you've read about it
but my question for yourself
I live I spend a lot of time in China
and and I know leaders and I and I see
both perspectives and I want to try to
be as accurate as I possibly can in
painting those perspectives okay
there was a hierarchy and in most large
companies in the United States you would
not have a vote and an election as to
who's operating it and so it's a
top-down kind of management in which the
government is working in the
coordination of its private sector and
its public sector extremely involved
right now exactly and they would say it
seems so crazy not to be I mean so a
leader of China described it as follows
okay he said and and this will help you
understand the Chinese on mentality and
because you have you you you know Iran
and you know the United States if one
needs to suspend biases in order to try
to hear the others perspective and so
what a leader in China described to me
said the essence of the difference
between the United States and China is
what is the unit of map that matters in
the United States it is the individual
it is individualism and it is the
individual and everything is bottom-up
you know it's the entrepreneur you elect
your government from bottom up and and
so on so it's a bottom-up type of
process companies are put together by
people who all want to make money
together they find it and they come
together and they make it bottom up but
it's bottom up if you want to build a
highway okay individual property rights
will matter a lot more in the United
States so an individual can almost stand
in the way that high would be if you
have a mission to get something done
individuals can stand in the way or
facilitate it so that's bottom-up and he
said in China the unit is with the
family and when if you understand
Confucianism Confucianism is for China
what judeo-christian roots is for the
United States and that starts with the
family and it says if you know how to
run your family well and there are rules
for running your family well according
to confusion and and then you know how
to enter
with your family interacting with the
greater society you have order but it's
very paternal paternal means okay your
responsibility it's top-down so when
they so there's a variant they when
they're running the government it would
be very similar to maybe running a big
company here that they would say okay
well there's top-down which produces
better results I'm not going to get that
that we can ask but yes I get put in all
kind of philosophy so it's top-down so
so the courts a complicated question
right the important thing what so I'll
give you what my thoughts are on that in
their experience when I first started
going there which was in 1984 since 1984
they have increased their incomes by an
average of 26 times they've gone from 2%
of GDP to 22% of GDP
they had a poverty rate which was 88%
it's now gone to less than 1%
they have lengthened the life expectancy
by 10 years I'm not saying which is gone
better or not but I'm saying they
believe and when you look at it that
that process is a logical process and it
works well and so that is the one that
they're operating by I grew up in
America which was a land of opportunity
for me and this goes back to what I'm
saying in terms it's got to be a land of
opportunity but I grew up in and and all
I had were two parents who loved me and
I went to a public school and and I
believed in this opportunity and that
that element of those types of freedoms
to create that that that opportunity
right now in the United States we have a
problem in the public education system
in terms of the quality certain areas
which are can't receive basic funding
for basic things the most basic things
because money doesn't get to them
they would say well that would be
intolerable how do we get deal with it
we have our own problem
so that each has a elements of pros and
cons they could say listen having my
company's work with my government if it
let's say on research if I was to take
AI research or if we take Huawei or
companies like that and you would say
well there in earlier years in earlier
decades there was funding for original
research if it's just the exact profit
motive before you make it it may not be
that the best results are necessarily
always dealt with particularly the
profit moment so they might say listen
we'll put money into development now we
would say in a I think a maybe too
black-and-white way that putting money
into the development by the government
making some of those moves would not be
our way of doing it from profit down and
so if you look but if you look at let's
say what DARPA is come up with in terms
of where the internet came from and
where GPS came from so there are issues
my main point is let's step back from
that the question you're asking me is
irrelevant
which what I like it doesn't matter I
mean you know because the pros and cons
because the issue really is will they
have the right to do it their way you
know what let me just finish will they
have the right to do with that show that
way or no there is a question around the
right because will they do it that way
and will we do it our way
and then you have the real conflict okay
because the real conflict when you get
down to the nitty-gritty of that
conflict is they say the team I'm going
to put on is going to be a government
company partnership type of thing okay
and we will choose not to have as much
of a government partnership and then we
argue about what the rules of the game
are and that's where the hardball starts
to come in right because what are the
rules it again I don't know if I yeah it
whatever way you want to run your family
you're on your family it's not my
business no but wait what I'm saying to
you as China wants to run it with those
rules go be at it no but you're not
understanding what I'm trying to say no
no I'm trying to make
we're when you're when there's a
question of an intersection what are the
rules of a game the United States and
China would disagree well that's where
the nubs the rubs come in other words if
Huawei is a company which has a
tremendous lead in 5g technology and
what an American perspective and the
rules would be that China pumping money
into Wow way is not the way the rules
should be okay
China would say well that's for you to
say and then and so they'll argue but if
more for this top-down versus bottom-up
that okay you're trying to do business
with me in my community
you got to play by my rules not you yeah
that's right it's not so clear-cut
that's the point but but if the whole
thing with the CFO and the whole you
know Iran and side you with another
company nobody
you get what I'm asking you no but I'm
saying if you're going to do business
with us and the community wouldn't it
have to be by the rules that us of
course each can operate by its rules
within its domain however it doesn't
work that way okay because of how
intertwined they are okay because of how
intertwined a1 technology is for another
if I was to recount what goes into our
technologies are there technologies and
the world that we've gone through has
been intertwined the globalization has
meant that companies get this piece from
the other and that piece from the other
and there were trade routes and now
we're having to go through a division of
those because it would be easy to say
when you're in my domain but the world
doesn't work like the domain is cut and
isolated and you're just within it
because the products are not just within
it if you take an Apple phone if you
take Apple devices if you take a lot of
things that we're using or vice versa
they are intertwined and that is where
the rub is I'm very familiar with that
I'm very familiar with how many
phones are in China and how much
business they allowed us to go in and
how much you know 5g is playing the
influence with Huawei and they were
getting to the systems even though they
weren't selling a lot of phones yeah I
understand that part with the race for y
way how big of a race for 5g is today
the only thing I'm asking is principle
wise a power force controlled no free
press no one really knows what their
unemployment is they'll say 30.8 but no
one really knows would you say it's a
competition and with that competition
whatever it is you will have our bottom
up they'll have their top down they'll
be control and will be this and and so
on and that's how it'll work and so
let's look at that both objectively and
then just also understand what they're
doing and what their perspective is
because if you don't understand their
perspective and you just paint it as you
know a good evil thing whatever it is or
I don't want it I don't think it's a
good evil think that's not what I'm
asking I'm saying if America doesn't
take a stand for what made them great
and they start compromising their
beliefs and principles to make other
empires happy we are getting weaker we
don't become the leaders that Islam no
but I couldn't agree with then we
wouldn't have any disagreement if that's
all you're saying okay because I
couldn't agree with that statement
analysts say well you know you know it's
okay if China is doing this we have to
understand their way of living we
understand their way of living I just
don't know if I want to compromise my
like the other day I asked a question
from somebody I said would I rather have
my government control me or a
corporation control me meaning they have
a spy on me what I rather have the US
government spy on me or have a
corporation spy on me well I'd rather
have the corporation spying me why
because their motive is really going to
be what profit okay but if the
government is maybe they're trying to
get data would I have control from
another country having access over me I
don't know so this is all things that I
myself do that's that's that's fine all
we're really doing I think is saying
there are two teams that are coming on
the field and there are two different
approaches to those okay and now let's
look at each one I would say the biggest
issue in the United States is how do we
be as great as we can be and that's
where my greater worry is because at the
end of the day
what's going to happen is if we are as
strong and capable as we can be and it's
great as we can be we will be good for
ourselves and we will be good for the
world the best in in the event of any
conflict I agree with that okay and that
my worry is more about that okay than
anything else
perfect do you want if we go into this
article yes you're incredibly written I
love that I enjoyed it I highlighted
made some notes and I brought some
boards if anything you wanted a show to
kind of highlight the points so when I
read this I wrote three things down here
on the side quotes on what you said in
your one you said most capitalists don't
know how to divide the economic pie well
and most socialists don't know how to
grow it as well okay then you said
meaning capitalists kind of maybe or
like hey let me go compete I want it all
and socials like well I don't really
know how to grow my thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars fair to one's income
growth results from one's productivity
growth which results from one's personal
development this leads me to one of the
points you'll make about education which
I want to cover and then last one I
caught here was I believe that all good
things taken to an extreme become self
destructive and everything must evolve
or die and that these principles now
apply to capitalism do you believe the
basic fundamentals of capitalism is an
evergreen philosophy I'm a professional
capitalistic capitalism has made my life
what it is and and I and I love
capitalism when you use the word
evergreen I'm as I said there I think
everything needs to look evolve
everything needs to look at its problems
and say what are its problems and change
and if it doesn't look at its problems
and change it is in danger of dying and
so when I look at capitalism now and I
go into this I hope anybody who's in
this interview will take the time to
read this so that they don't make a
stereotypical view highly recommend you
read the article highly I'll put the
link below as well okay thank you but
what what what it is
certain outcomes and those outcomes are
things like is this a country that I
love the things I grew up with is this a
country of equal opportunity can we
share the notion what is our overarching
principle can we share it just like you
described when you came from around I
think this is a country in which it was
fabulous in being able to bring people
without prejudice from anywhere in the
world and they can really be citizens
here in a way where based on their
opportunity and their good behavior but
in addition that are the the thing that
I grew up with and I always believed was
most important was equal opportunity so
if I would say what is America it's a
notion it's a country of equal
opportunity and circumstances have
changed this was not because of evilness
of anybody but circumstances have
changed having to do with combination
things having to do with technologies
replacing jobs and certain types of jobs
having to do with going global and the
workforce being a global workforce where
others will in those jobs produce it
outside the United States and bring it
in having to do with monetary policy
which means that the central bank's buy
financial assets which benefits those
who have financial assets relative to
those having to do the way the
Constitution is even written as regards
that who is responsible for education
aid or federal it's a state issue by the
Constitution and it is and and and so
then you would say as I examine them
that's I just wanted to see the
differences so I I carved it away I want
to look at what the bottom 60% of the
population what their lives are like and
separated it from the top forty percent
because the averages are misleading and
really that's almost like an 80/20 thing
in other words the bottom 80% of the
relative to the top 20 because that
other group is not it's basically
similar to the bottom
and and it's not an environment in which
we can say that we are striving well for
equal opportunity okay opportunity
because in that top 40 percent the
average per capita amount of money spent
on a child's education is five times
that in the lower 60% and so if you look
at the outcomes not put the outcomes of
income aside for a bit
but just even deal with productivity and
usefulness and you look at the tragedy
of not being able to get adequate number
of books in places or adequate teachers
and and then you say is that productive
and is it fair it's not productive
because you're losing an education of a
large percentage of the population the
proper education the proper care we also
have family issues families are breaking
apart
in other words like I said I had the
benefit of two parents who love me and
took care of that in some of these cases
that you have a problem of that there's
not good family guidance and and and and
that's a whole social issue but it
becomes a spiral and so I think the
question is are we going to look at that
well and how do we deal with it in a
non-partisan non-ideological ah
ideological way right so okay so the
whole part we talk about the kids being
raised without married parents I think
1960 73% were today's thirty eight
percent you know that don't have both
and the numbers obviously higher than
it's ever been today but and I'm not
just saying marry maybe you live on
married or maybe there are different
kinds of forms of households but I am
saying the guidance in somewhere of a
loving person at least right or two
better for the care of those children is
an important determinant that and basic
education these are important
determinants so you you think a lot of
the references you make here goes to 30s
and referencing cow you know the top 1%
in the 30s versus today you know you
showed this that the top 1% in the 30s
versus today you know top 1% income
share has the same amount as the bottom
90% in the last time it was like that in
the authorities are you kind of
suggesting that we may be facing what
happened in the 30s years or no yes I'm
saying you so that is why I'm saying
there are three major divisions okay
three major forces and that force which
i think i emphasized the opportunity gap
not just the wealth gap but they both
matter if you look at history across
countries across timeframes
and you say when there's a large income
and wealth gap and you have an economic
downturn you have a dangerous fight on
your hands you have a dangerous set of
circumstances history has taught us that
you said in April income inequality is
the biggest crisis we have in America on
60 minutes and I think in recent a
couple months ago you said wealth
inequality those are the two main things
that we ought to become I'm not saying
an even more fundamental those are the
outcomes and even more fundamental is
opportunity in quality and production
inequality because at the end of the day
just like you said we have to find how
to make this thing work well and you you
quoted me as saying correctly that I
think that the capitalists know how to
make it better and the Socialists know
how to maybe divide it okay but what
they've got to do is they've got to get
in there there are things that we could
do that will make our country more equal
opportunity and more productive such as
what as well where you're going to put
the education part but there's so many
different there's so many different
things but certainly basic equality and
education if you go back to the most
basic that dough oh okay
but first you have to start with the
following beliefs number one that we
must deal with the issue okay that you
treat that risky situation not at
and political division that exists like
this as a national crisis that we better
get on looking at it's okay what a lot
of different countries try to do with it
you're not letting me answer your
question cuz I'm sorry my answers are
too long but if you I have to okay
you've got to do it you've got to do it
together okay you got it
first of all treat it as I'm adjust your
interview style you you your answers are
long-winded and I got I'm sorry I'm
gonna make notes no you go I'm gonna
make notes and I'll come back and visit
it please continue
okay yeah I am long-winded no it's good
the content is good but you're um you're
getting me to ask a question from
certain things you're saying cuz I'm
curious I know and I feel at some that I
can't answer complete the answer and
that's my dilemma when I'm you know so I
don't know you tell me because you know
it's your it's your interview so do you
tell me how to do it I think we as a
country have got to come together and
realize that we share a common problem
of this polarity and that it should be
first declared as a national emergency
okay and and that it should be done in a
knowledgeable and bipartisan way I don't
think it's gonna happen but I think it's
necessary to happen because otherwise
you'll have a fight and this that fight
will itself be very damaging and that
you have to then engineer it so that you
both increase productivity and you
increase a fair system and you can do
that I gave example you could do it by
education you could do it by a number of
things I won't that's where it led him
to your question your question was then
how would you do that in education that
that was your follow-up to that sure and
I am my example and I would say if you
start with the will and the necessity
and you did the engineering with the
knowledgeable part partners in various
ways you can get there the capacity of
the individual so does that mean for
example you might carry it forward in
the following way you would say now
just raise taxes but say what are our
needs that we have to meet and how much
money is it going to take to meet those
needs and you start with not just a
redistribute the money okay we have to
redistribute the money but you start
with the critical necessity like we need
to approach at equal education or
something approaching equal education so
you put that in and you'd say how and
how do I build that out and I could tell
you lots of ways I encountered all the
time in education my wife and I are very
active in terms of dealing with that on
a nitty-gritty basis and I could tell
you that money put into education in a
certain way can have a catalytic
enormous benefit that will change that
will have an economic benefit as a
social benefit because if you look at
for example what it takes to take a
child through high school education okay
it doesn't take there's there programs
that we're working on the my wife is
leading and in Connecticut 100 million
dollars I saw that but but also on that
comes from a nitty-gritty on the gum on
the ground doing this for ten year kind
of perspective that to get a child to go
through to make it through high school
or not and into a job doesn't cost that
much
okay now you compare that with the cost
of not doing that what that has in terms
of the differences in the crime rates
the differences in the incarceration
rates do you know that to incarcerate a
person cost between 80 and 120 thousand
dollars a year okay you got a fifty
billion dollar of cost right there for
you right now so you can change I
cost-effectively you could give better
opportunity and you can make it more
advantageous because you'll create more
productive people rather than less
productive people so the discussion of
how to engineer that is not taking place
so I'm telling you a myth discussions
taking place no no I'm saying no I'm
saying the thing you don't think people
would want to be able to help no I'm
saying it's you're asking me is it
taking place you're saying no what I'm
saying
is not taking place so here what I'm
saying is there declare it as a national
emergency no okay
is our people with the real perspectives
of both perspectives operating in a
nonpartisan or bipartisan way to deal
with that problem no okay
it is progress being made to deal with
that problem
No yeah are they dealing with the
cost-effectiveness of that dollar to
produce a better dollar we're about them
so you asked me examples I could give
you many many many examples in which
there are cost-effective ways to make
more people productive and make the
system fair and I'm saying it's not
going to happen and it's not it's
tragically not going to happen because
you have these two sides so you have the
let's say the socialist undermining
entrepreneurship or or the American
dream okay in many ways and in terms of
changing things or you have the
capitalist who is essentially not
recognizing what the dilemma is for that
other percentage of the population
that's how it looks to me is it fair to
say that in order for this to also
improve we have to leave the freedom to
fail up to the populist as well or else
we're going to other regimes that are
controlling their people let me explain
what I mean by this if I'm if I'm trying
to make any influence in the country
like for myself I grew up in a family
welfare my mom and then my mom was on
welfare she ran out of money she went
back to Iran I stayed here I joined the
army went for two and a half years I had
a 1.8 GPA in high school I'm a calculus
kid I did good in calculus everything
else I wasn't good at so I go to the
army I get out a kid calls me friend of
mine says I think you'd do better out of
the army I'm about to relist ago Special
Forces Sears Rangers I got all the
orders I'm gonna go to DL I speak five
languages that we're gonna use me this
is gonna be a great guy to keep for 20
years I'd be a great soldier in the
military he calls me society you can do
good in the free market so what do you
mean says you should get out so I get
out then a man my first boss and my
sister recommend me to pick up a book
and
I start reading then I get inspired then
I get failed miserably and then I make a
few hundred million dollars of my 30s
that that happened because someone said
hey what do you want to do with this but
the same person that offered me a book
offered 50 other people to read a book
you understand this this is it all right
that's the American Dream what I'm
trying to say is but the point I'm
trying to say that for you your
background you shouldn't be worth
eighteen point seven billion dollars
today based on stats your dad's last
names not Vanderbilt or Kennedy or its
value and you made value irrelevant to
the world where the world world Moses
let me finish my statement and I'm also
gonna be a little bit long-winded here
please don't turn the wind back over to
I promise you I think sometimes when we
try to encourage the populace to do
something if we go the route of a more
entitlement entitlement entitlement but
the kid is coming home to the wrong
mindset nothing is changing so how much
it is is this to work on the parents of
the eight-year-old PBB or their 12 year
old rate value how much of it is on the
parents to want to also do something
about it and want to pick up a book want
to develop themselves as it is on the
kid because I think we're forgetting the
influence of who the kid is going home
to I'm not forgetting that okay I'm
talking about parenting right I mean
that's one of my bigger come on that's
one of my big things the only again how
do we influence them well I think you I
think you've just said I want to
emphasize the things that you said
because that's the American dream okay
the American Dream is made up of the
fact that you own it you acquired early
on the the good guidance from adults and
ideal your parents and you had an
education system that was a fair
education system that you can get
through and there you went and then you
had you and your self discovery process
and your character that allowed you to
do that in in the process of doing that
not only did you take care of yourself
you produce such great outcomes and the
results that the consequence you are a
real net contributor and so when we look
at the
we have to make these people net
contributors unless somebody's
handicapped if somebody can't for
whatever their inability and that's a
social program you have to give those
other people essentially the opportunity
to struggle well to be able to struggle
well and to develop the character and
the capabilities that come from
struggling well that's the formula so we
agree on that formula and so if we have
a situation where we're failing because
you can go to school districts and I
know the school districts in which they
don't can't afford each kid to have a
book enough books or in some places not
enough to have pencils at each kid
having adequate pencils so they break
them in half and sharpen them from both
directions so that they can get by and
doing that and you have that and we look
at them we just don't look in the mirror
and say can what can we give them to
have that equal opportunity we have a
problem because the way it's now laid
out to me it looks like is that there
was a one political party or one view
that becomes extremely one-way that in
terms of saying okay don't how do you
create that that desire that opportunity
that need to be productive and do don't
give just the money give the means by
which you're going to operate and you
have another political party who was
saying I will not deal with
restructuring it so that we produce the
outcomes that are necessary to create
that education and create that equal
opportunity so when I look at each one
of them it's a scary choice because I
don't think that either of them is
creating that process and unless we come
to do it and we'd stop talking like
corporations are bad or our billionaires
are bad
you know most fill language to boast
most most billionaires became I'm an
accidental billionaire and most people
became accident billionaires because
what they did is they produce something
of value that people wanted whether it's
millionaires to get million three or
just earning a good job you're producing
something that some
wants and in producing something that
someone wants they pay you for it and
the more you produce that somebody wants
the more they pay you and that's the way
the system is and that entrepreneurship
and all of that is a very important
thing that's why equal opportunity
people from all over the world came to
the United States for that okay so now
if we can agree on that
and how do we do that deal with it in a
in a way we're together we're working on
that rather than just want to get trying
to kill the other
and then undermining that we won't fix
ourselves and we need to fix ourselves
because if you're looking at the world
and you're saying okay now you're
competing with the world you're
competing with China one way or another
we got to make our system work well then
the final question for you would be in
this areas I read a book a few years ago
by Lawrence Miller titled the barbarians
to be repressed never sold a lot of
copies great book I called him one time
I said Lawrence how do more people not
know about your books I'm not a good
marketer I just wrote the book and he
says how there's a prophet first the
visionary first and then there's a the
barbarians I'll go out there make it
happen sometimes a prophet is also the
barber you know like maybe a Steve Jobs
a prophet barbarian builder explorer
administrator bureaucrat aristocrat okay
so America is kind of getting at this
face of bureaucrat aristocrat yeah
that's right that's what we are that's
right but then he says that during these
times is when you can give birth to a
synergist right that brings it together
where does the sinner just come to bring
the left and the right because you know
the media is not playing the sin or just
the media is kind of dividing over
that's right so okay becomes a sin no
but I think I think he's created what is
a beautiful description and I will ask
having read history and watched
dynasties rise and decline and empires
rise and decline I have never seen the
sinner just you've never seen this
energy I've never seen the synergist so
I want an example of the synergist what
I have seen happen over and over again
is this decline he's the client he's
describing that notion also one
generation to another that what happens
is it's the person who doesn't have
anything works our accomplishes some
thing has it and so on the synergist
I've never seen the synergist all I've
seen in history is these people
deteriorating that leadership
deteriorating and those people fighting
that's what I've seen repeatedly in
history that's what I'm saying it
happened in the 1930s but it happened
I've studied this going back literally I
had to study I wanted to stay the last
500 years to understand the rises in
declining of Empires and if I go to I've
studied before this the British Empire
before that the Dutch Empire I started
the Spanish Empire
I studied the dynasties in China and
they all have the same paths they all
basically have the same paths and those
paths are an optimistic it's the same
thing as even companies it's a company
path or think of a multi-generational
family you know the first generation
makes it they work on the second
generation and that's why they go from
the same from shirt sleeves the shirt
sleeves in three generations okay if you
think about the company the corporation
corporation starts with an entrepreneur
and then it goes to the cycle he's
describing and then you get to the
bureaucrat okay and then somebody who's
the entrepreneur and scrappy like you or
whatever those people come up and
they're the revolutionaries and they
tear it down because they come up with
better ways of doing it and those are
what the patterns look like you said in
an interview are not competitive or
you're driven I'm sorry you said in an
interview I'm not competitive or you're
very driven using it okay okay so I'm
curious and I'm passionate how involved
are you in encouraging this conversation
and dialogue to take place if you think
income inequality and wealth inequality
and opportunity and equality if you
think those three our national crisis
how come you national emergency how come
you're not leading that charge to bring
and unify the groups together because
you have credibility and you know like
my ability my look power come comes with
the extent of the role I met a state so
I'll
back and I'll describe where my what my
you know
sure sure sure and I'm trying to answer
it and like any of my answers you have
to be because they take a couple of
minutes okay but for the first is where
I am in my life I think there are three
phases in one's life first days is
you're dependent on others in your
learning then you go out in the world
and you're increasingly others become
dependent on you and you're working and
you're trying to be successful then you
approach the third phase where I'm in a
phase where I'm going to my third phase
and in that third phase my goal is to
have other people be successful without
me and that's like extends to your kids
extents other thing so the reason I'm
passing along these things is because
III hope that they're helpful the reason
we're doing this interview I'm not doing
it for money okay I'm not doing for any
other reason that I hope it's helpful
and so I'm passing that along it's so
much dependent on other people to make
their choices one Crusader is going to
come in there I'm not running for
president I'm not running I'm not gonna
be in that position of control that is
not where I am I'm just hoping that I
could pass along my thoughts for people
to take it or leave it and leave it up
to them right so so do I want to build
what do I want to go run for government
government or anything you're we're in a
situation if you don't have your hands
on the levers of power it doesn't matter
okay so because I agree you because you
can only have to convince the people who
have their hands on the lover of power
so the only thing I could do is give my
best thoughts for people to take or
leave it and that's where I am so do you
think there's any room today for a media
company to come out that is Walter
Cronkite
esque you know a platform that's not Fox
that's not CNN MSNBC time whoever it is
Washington Post that's in the middle
where somebody can go to and say you
know what he's I don't know fine I'm a
Democrat but I don't know if I agree but
makes sense I'm a Republican I that's
kind of make do you think we need
something there were pee
Gotha to say these guys are pretty
independently thinking under state maps
absolutely do I think it will happen
probably not why do you say that history
has shown me and also I study psychology
and neuroscience as to how the brain
works and how habit and community
decision making in in a psychological
neural neurological way is very much
that you start with your conclusion and
you m1 filters consistent with the
conclusion and there's affinity groups
and so on and so I think that just the
notion of that population deviating from
that and also the mechanics of
sensationalism in terms of what sells
yeah that it produces a dynamic in which
the media itself is not going for the
profit and the economics itself of the
media is such that it doesn't sell it
doesn't support itself I don't think
there's a large enough market and I
think it's being exemplified by the
power of extremism or illogical
emotional behavior so it almost need to
be somebody that wants to contribute
rather than want it to profit from but I
don't even know how them how big the
market is what you buy it would you
subscribe to it well of course I had my
one of my sons came up with a platform
but what he would do was it would it was
an online he saw past the idea along I
thought it was a terrific idea just a
social site that on oh he called it the
issue that was the name of the company
and it's an on site and on that issue
whenever there was a controversial point
of view all he would do was find the
smartest people who held different
points of view on that and he would put
together two or three of those which had
then the opposite point of view on that
and you would look at that and so you
could say I'm interested in the issue
and seeing both and by the way anybody
can do this all it all into the world
you could just I hope somebody gets
inspired to do that so you could then
say I can get informed on both presides
of the perspective of that issue I was
supporting a major correspondent type of
person to bring on - to have the name of
the show was going to be in pursuit of
truth and they would find opposing
points of view on any issue and have the
default full debate about those issues
the first one we we did actually a pilot
for it and it was called picked the most
controversial point of view God reality
or delusion we picked you could take
this thing or that whatever the rule
that picked the most controversial
things and have a civil conversation
about those types of things in terms of
seeing both sides of the issue it's a
real big thing for me i think dennis
prager did a little bit of that with
thomas solo when I was in LA we'd go to
Wayne Hughes house and he would bring
all these guys from both sides like
Obama's campaign manager versus Bush's
campaign manager and they'd go at it and
it was beautiful
it's like you're sitting at home taking
notes you only got one question in it
and then you realize issues are more
complicated than they could be may exact
writing you see similarities I know I'm
alehrer cheese we're like why these guys
have more in common than you thought and
they walk away to like in each other
yeah I mean these are smaller settings
yeah love like like and let's let's book
our agreements let's get the ingredients
so could we agree that education better
education is an important thing could we
agree on those problems and then work
together for that man I'm where we need
to go yes last question in and I'll do
speed running and we're done
process of replacing yourself as a CEO I
know you're spoken about it but now it's
a little bit deeper because it's
different than you wrote in the book
then even articles you written in the
last two years I'm curious where you are
right now if you have to go over again
to replace yourself and bring another
CEO and you're the founder so
emotionally you're attached that's your
culture your principles how do you
process and what are you thinking about
to get somebody to bring in and what
you're looking for it is it
internal-external are you comfortable
external being a CEO how do you process
replaced well let me let me again start
with the big particular picture it is
stupid to be attached to the ways that
should be done or attached to one doing
the job of being a CEO that is a stupid
thing because there's a certain life arc
and we evolve and as I say to go to the
third phase and that let them go to the
second and that's why be helping others
be successful without you is the higher
objective so first you have to start and
you say that because it's like your
children let's say you have adult
children you know your parents the best
thing that could happen is they smile
and they look at you and they see how
you evolved along those ways so you have
to want that that that becomes your arc
the second thing is that you have to
realize that like anything if you
haven't done something of a principle if
you haven't done something three times
before successfully don't assume you
know how to do it so all along those
lines as you start off you have to allow
enough time for mistakes and learning
that's going to come along the way in
order to be able to make that transition
successfully and I've learned that over
there you know it was a process first
time around it didn't work second time
around but we all learn because all
these experiences are learning that's
the purpose of them all so it's okay to
fail a few of these times and then to
get there as long as you eventually get
there and then you have to you know help
them so yeah you know enable them
enablement is the word not control an
able be an orator or personality like
you do oh it's so great it's a
partnership if the the first thing I
first sentences in this book that I
wrote first of all understand that I'm a
dumb and anything that I have I
haven't done you're seeing like you
have to know I'm a dumb oh you're
dumb in other words that what I
mean is that any success I've had in my
life yeah
mordioux to mine knowing how to deal
with what I don't know
then would then do to anything I know
okay once you start to realize that and
the power does not just listen bottled
up in your own head okay and you can
draw upon the best then you can then you
change your approach to life and I'd say
it's the opposite the greatest tragedy
of mankind or the greatest tragedy of
individuals who together make up mankind
in their dealing with each other is they
have bottled up in their heads wrong
opinions that they don't know how does
stress test because it they think if
it's in their heads and it's it's right
if they have an opinion and it's so easy
to get around that if you can think
about how do I go beyond that with true
so the reason I'm saying that is I love
partnerships in which there's a
back-and-forth and you knock things
around and you get to the right answer
where there's open mindedness and
learning at the same time as there's the
assertiveness as you're trying to figure
things out together very cool last thing
is speed Ron I give a name you just give
me a word that comes to your mind
okay I'll give a name you give me one
word Buffett a wise Lawrence called when
he was a CEO of Danaher metrics
interesting Boris Johnson loose cannon
okay 1994 Newt Gingrich accomplishment
Joe Biden who knows Milton Friedman
naive Michael Bloomberg well balanced
and capable Jeff Bezos interesting Peter
Thiel don't know enough okay very cool
so I appreciate you going through that
that was fascinating value Tanner's
before I wrap this up couple things
number one highly highly recommend the
first thing you do is go in the
description section there's gonna be a
link to the first one go download his
app principles you'll see it we're gonna
put the link it'll go right to it and
even through it if you ask you download
the app you want to get the book the
second link below
leave its to go to the book principles
I've read this multiple times I have
every single one of my executives read
it and write a paper on it I have every
single one of my sales leaders read it
and write a paper on it because it's
that effective of a book if you haven't
read it you got to read it having said
that Rea thank you so much for your time
I'm looking forward to doing this again
in the future I look forward to it too
thank you hope you enjoyed this
interview with Ray Dalio I know we
talked about a lot of different things
but I want to hear your thoughts send me
a tweet at Patrick Bay David let me know
what's the biggest takeaway from this
sit-down I had with Ray Dalio
and outside of it I got two other videos
I want you to watch one video is a one I
did on us-china trade war that did very
well got a few million views you can
click on this to wash it us-china trade
war or the other video is on wall way
since we talked about China and we
talked about Huawei in this interview
you may also enjoy those videos having
said that if you haven't subscribed to
the channel please do so take everybody
bye-bye
[Music]